for the
secretary general of the united nations
antonio guterres
what a pleasure to have you here and a
warm welcome to the european commission
first of all let me congratulate you for
your second
appointment or the appointment for a
second mandate
i think the united nations are very
lucky
and can be very grateful to have you at
the helm of this
big institution and i wanted to
assure you that and you know that the
european union and the european
commission
always stand by your side we support you
in your tireless work to strengthen
multilateralism
and to improve the rules-based order
globally for all the topics we are
dealing with together be it peace and
security
or the support for refugees or
overcoming the pandemic
but also fighting climate change so we
are
very happy that we have you here today
in our college
um we are of course also supporting you
on your reform agenda
and very curious on what you call our
common agenda where we always volunteer
to take a leading role so once again
a very warm welcome well thank you very
much
it's a great pleasure to be back the
european union and in particular
european commission has been a very
strong supporter everywhere in all the
dimensions of our work
and so this is a moment to express my
deep gratitude and appreciation
on the other hand if it is true that
today i am a
leading universal organization i
am a european and as a european i'm
particularly proud
with the the contribution that i can see
the most important contribution of
europe
to global civilization and that is in my
opinion the enlightenment the values of
the enlightenment the privacy of reason
tolerance
and this is particularly important when
we see the risks of moving into a kind
of a post-enlightenment
era and where we see the multiplication
of different forms of irrationality uh
nationalism populism racism xenophobia
anti-semitism uh anti-muslim hatreds
and i believe that the european union is
and we count on the european union to be
on the forefront
of the good battle for the values of the
enlightenment
which were as i mentioned the very
important contribution of europe to
global civilization
thank you thank you so very much oh yes
we need our masks again
thank you